-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning
comedian and writer.
He's performing
his one-man show,
"The Movement You Need,"
through November 7th
at the SoHo Playhouse.
Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Brendan Hunt, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, my friend.
-Hi, buddy.
-It's very nice to see you
the day after Halloween.
Because I've known you
for 20 years.
You have made some of the bolder
sartorial choices
over the years,
and so I was very excited
that you were going to get
to spend Halloween in New York
and very curious as to
what you would dress as,
and, as often,
it was super confusing.
-Yeah, yeah,
I have a knack for, like,
combo-platter Halloween costumes
that never work out.
One year I was --
I went through three stages
on, like, a party bus
where I was dressed as Neo.
-Yeah.
-Then later I added
a Super Mario hat and mustache
and I was Mar-Neo.
-Yeah.
-And then later,
most unsuccessfully,
I added a long, curly black wig,
and I was Mar-Neo Speedwagon.
-Yeah.
-No. No, no.
-If somebody had come up to you
and gone, "Mar-Neo Speedwagon,"
you would have known
you were in the Matrix.
This is all simulation.
Alright, so this is
the Arsenal goalkeeper,
who also plays
for the U.S. national team.
-Yes.
-So he dressed
like your television character
last year.
-Yes.
-And his name is Matt?
-Matt Turner.
-Now at Nottingham Forest.
-Okay, so now Nottingham.
So Matt Turner was your --
'cause you were gonna
repay the favor.
He dressed like you.
You were gonna dress like him.
-Yes.
-But that's too easy.
-I didn't want to go
straight Matt Turner.
So I decided I would add
a little something,
and I went with Bat Turner.
-Bat Turner.
So...anybody yell out,
"Oh, Bat Turner"?
-No. In fact, I only got
to go to one party,
and the people there --
Like, I was, like,
you know, sat down, had dinner,
had the mask off.
And finally, "Yeah,
so I'm Bat Turner,
and Matt Turner
is a goalkeeper."
"Oh, thank you.
God. Okay, great."
-But then you didn't let it go.
You were like, "I'm gonna
amp it up one more time."
-Well, the opportunity arose.
-So you were...
-Bat Ternie.
-Okay.
The best thing here is, like,
you clearly --
You're just in
a different part of the kitchen.
And, by the way,
I want to point out,
there's no other people
at this party.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, congratulations
on the show.
I've always, you know --
I think a lot of people here
know you from television.
I got to know you onstage.
I love watching you onstage.
This is not your first
one-man show,
but this is probably
the most personal one-man show.
-Yeah, yeah,
it's basically looking at
my mom and I's relationship,
which was complicated,
like so many
mom relationships are.
But we had, like,
one avenue of clarity
and, you know, no conflict,
which was our love
of The Beatles,
which she had engendered in me
and she was 100% right about.
-And so you guys
always had that.
Even when times were tough,
you connected on The Beatles.
You were a big Beatles fan even,
I mean, as a kid
because of your mom.
So tell me why
you would sign "The Beatles"
in other people's yearbooks.
-Yeah, so,
in my yearbook picture,
I'm wearing
a pin of The Beatles.
It's the Beatles butcher cover.
Google it. It's great.
And somehow, some way,
Kenwood Academy,
2,200-person student body,
not a single other music act
is represented
in the entire yearbook.
Not a T-shirt, not a poster.
The Beatles.
And so I was so proud of this
that when I would sign
people's yearbooks,
I would go to my picture
and I would write "The Beatles"
just to make extra sure
they knew that The Beatles
were in their yearbook.
-The weird thing is,
you look more
like young Henry Winkler
than he did.
[ Laughter ]
Is this a friend
that wrote this?
-Yeah, so all that Beatles stuff
didn't make me popular.
Eventually,
one of my best friends
decided to deface
my own yearbook with,
"Buttcrust Beatles Suck Fan."
And to his credit,
I've never heard the word
"buttcrust" before or since.
-Yeah, no.
It's a real --
Try it once and then
abandon it forever.
You talk about
one of your first --
or a memory that I guess
has stuck over the years
is your mom introducing you
to "Yellow Submarine."
-Yeah, so, when you're trying
to think about
what your first memory is, like,
you can't really know for sure.
You're never holding a calendar.
So I have two nominees,
and they're both similar
'cause I'm in the doorway
watching my mom,
and she's sitting
in both options.
The one, yes, lovely,
she's watching a cartoon.
It's late at night.
I can't sleep.
And she sits me down,
says, "Nana, come here."
My nickname was Nana.
I couldn't say "Brendan."
I said "Nana."
-Yeah.
-And she's like,
"This is 'Yellow Submarine.'"
And I have a specific memory
of John Lennon,
like, climbing the tower
of the lyrics
of "All You Need Is Love" that
he was making with his mouth.
And I was like,
"That's really cool."
And history will show such
sentimental displays of love
not really my mom's wheelhouse,
because the other memory that
might be my first memory is,
again, I'm standing in
the doorway, and she's sitting,
but in this scenario,
she's sitting on the toilet
and she has her head
in her hands,
as she so often did,
and she's holding a cigarette,
and she sees me
and she sees the cigarette.
She goes, "What,
you want to try it?"
Like, "Sure."
So I smoked a cigarette
at 3 years old,
coughed my lungs out, and I've
never wanted a cigarette since.
Unorthodox but effective.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-When she went to the doctor
and was like,
"Why can't he say 'Brendan'?"
He's like, "I don't know.
Is he smoking?
When did he have
his first cigarette?"
[ Laughter ]
Hey, so we met at Boom Chicago,
and that's a comedy theater
in Amsterdam,
and they wrote a wonderful book
about the 30 most important
years in Dutch history.
It's very tongue-in-cheek.
It's really just a book about
this great theater
we were part of.
And it got to add a chapter
about the last five years
of what their alumni
have accomplished.
And, of course, you and
Jason Sudeikis and Joe Kelly --
there's a SAG strike,
so we can't get into it --
but you guys
wrote a very special show.
-Some show.
But, you know, #Believe.
It was very good.
And it's very cool to also hear
how your time in Amsterdam
informed that incredible
piece of writing.
-Yeah, it was nice of them
to do that extra,
'cause there was a 25-year
anniversary edition of the book.
It was nice of them
to do this extra book.
Suffice to say,
I was not on the cover
of the 25th-anniversary edition.
-Yeah, that's right.
That's the thing.
You were like, "You know what?
I'm gonna go out and make
some cover-worthy work."
Last thing, because again,
you've had a good five years.
You threw out the first pitch
at a Chicago White Sox game.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's not the worst picture.
You look like you might
be doing alright here.
-I did okay. I did okay.
-You did okay?
-The only goal
was not become a meme.
And it worked out.
-Yeah. That's the thing.
If you throw out a first pitch
and no one ever talks about it,
that's all you ever want,
'cause the only ones they talk
about are the real bad ones.
-Yeah. Please, just forget
about it completely.
-How much practice?
-With Joe Kelly,
the aforementioned Joe Kelly,
we went and threw
like three or four times.
Joe Kelly, former catcher.
-Okay. So that helps.
-But the practices
tended to be very short
because I'm old and I was like,
"Alright, whoo.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, Joe, I think that's
about enough for today.
Ohhh!"
-Well, it worked out.
And I'm very excited
for your show.
And it's so great
to have you here, buddy.
Thank you so much.
Brendan Hunt, everybody.
"The Movement You Need"
is playing
at the SoHo Playhouse
through November 7th.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."